the coronavirus did not stop the Supreme
Court from hearing arguments on whether
president Trump's Bank and accountants
can be forced to give investigators his
tax returns and other financial records
as Jan Crawford reports the potential
burden of congressional inquiries is a
key issue here at some point there's a
straw that breaks the camel's back over
more than three hours Supreme Court
justices focused on where investigations
become a presidential distraction there
is a long long history of Congress
seeking records and getting them at
stake whether House Democrats
investigating the president's business
dealings and a New York grand jury
looking into his campaign can subpoena
tax returns and other records mr. Trump
has long sought to keep private the
Supreme Court has told other presidents
to comply with court orders President
Nixon and Watergate President Clinton in
a sexual harassment lawsuit by Paula
Jones the presidency is being harassed
president transpersonal lawyer jay
sekulow argued his client has temporary
presidential immunity from such
subpoenas while in office some justices
seem skeptical of that argument and
appeared to search for a middle ground
how can we both protect the houses
interest in obtaining information it
needs to legislate but also protect the
presidency Jeffrey Rosen president of
the National Constitution Center says
the case is hard to predict you could
imagine the court sending both cases
back to lower courts and that means we
could be back at the Supreme Court again
but if that happens that would probably
be after the next presidential election
for CBS this morning Jan Crawford
Washington